oh ça fait longtemps qu'on dirait pas
tant que ça en fait juste vous êtes
addict égard la petite hache un qui
intervient dix secondes avant de tourner
bon l'assument je suis un gros porc
hockey vous connaissez le format trois
histoires d'horreur vrai mais qui
finissent bien rassurez vous vous n'êtes
pas là pour qu'on discute vous et moi
vous êtes là pour que je vous raconte
ses histoires
alors c'est parti la première histoire
celle de ain et de sa copine nadia se
passe en 2007 ça remonte à il ya pas mal
d'années et à cette époque là anne vient
d'avoir 15 ans elle vit seule avec sa
maman dans une maison située dans un
quartier plutôt tranquille mais la maire
de vannes est toujours très vigilante et
connaît un petit peu les dangers du
monde qui nous entoure et comme elle
doit partir en déplacement professionnel
pour plusieurs jours elle demande à sa
fille anne de dormir chez sa copine
nadia jusqu'à son retour sachant que sa
copine nadia habite dans la maison juste
en face de la sienne
donc c'est très proche et d'ailleurs
anne elle est un peu le simple quand sa
mère et lui dit d'aller dormir chez une
copine à elle parce qu'elle a
l'impression que sa mère lui fait pas
confiance ou qu'elle n'est pas assez
grande pour rester chez elles sol alors
qu'elle a quand même 15 en haïti
complexe d'adolescents tu connais mais
très bon flair la merde âme très bon
flair bref on est le dernier jour du
séjour de hann chez sa copine nadia il
est environ 23 heures tout se passe bien
les paroles nadia leur ont commandé des
pizzas et un peu plus tard aux alentours
de 22h30 les parents de nadia décide
d'aller chez des amis à eux qui habite
vraiment pas loin à environ 10 minutes
de route est donc allé nadia se retrouve
seul pendant environ une heure dans la
maison elle décide alors d'aller dans la
chambre de nadia de découvrir le nouveau
téléphone à clapet qu'a eu and pour son
anniversaire et ça croyez moi c'était
style et d'en avoir un à l'époque
et puis rapidement elle commence à
s'ennuyer puisque l on saigne et la ps3
elles ont saigné la découverte du
téléphone à clapet l as font chier mais
elles ont une idée un peu drôle
elles savent qu'il est trop tard pour
qu'elles appellent en leurs amis mais
elles savent aussi que la maman de hann
rentrer le lendemain matin avec le
premier truc qu'elle va faire en
rentrant c'est d'écouter la messagerie
de leurs téléphones fixes à 2007 1 c'est
notre époque elle se met d'accord et
leur plan c'est de laisser un message
vocal débile que la maman de hann
découvrirez en revanche ça me fait un
peu rire
je trouve l'idée pas si nuls elle
appelle donc le numéro du téléphone fixe
de la maison de hann
normalement il faut qu'ils aient cinq
sonneries avant de pouvoir laisser un
message sauf que là au bout de trois
sonneries
une loi qui dit une voix que anne décrit
comme appartenant à un homme d'environ
60 ans qui aurait fumé trois paquets de
cigarettes par jour les 40 dernières
années de sa vie année nadia reste
bouche bée
elles comprennent pas il s'attendait à
tout sauf à ça et puis la voix au bout
du fil si vous n'auriez pas dû appeler
avant de raccrocher année nadia son
panique nadia évidemment elle demande à
annecy elle sait qui était au bout du
fil
si c'est peut-être le nouveau copain de
sa maman son frère son nom et puis elles
ont évidemment le réflexe de vérifier
s'ils ont bien appeler le bon numéro de
téléphone alors elles sortent l'annuaire
elle vérifie et non c'est bien le numéro
de fixe de ham
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya bien en ce
moment même à 23 heures passées un homme
dont la maison de haan et qu'elle n'a
aucune idée de qui ça peut être
rassurez vous elles vont prendre la
bonne décision elles vont appeler
immédiatement les parents nadia pour les
prévenir tout en courant partout dans la
maison à vérifier que toutes les ports
sont bien verrouillés après quinze
longues minutes d'attentes les parents
de nadia sont de retour et 20 minutes
plus tard c'est la police qui arrive à
son tour dans la maison de nadia elle
explique aux policiers ce qui vient de
se passer et les policiers décident
évidemment d'aller enquêter dans la
maison de hyde et en arrivant devant la
maison surprise la porte d'entrée est
grande ouverte et ya aucun signe
d'effraction
évidemment ce soir là la mère de hann
est rentré en précipitations et les
policiers ont eu beau chercher dans tout
le quartier dans le jardin autour de la
maison dans la maison ils ont rien
trouvé
l'afer a donc été classée sans suite et
anne et sa maman malgré leurs faibles
moyens financiers à l'époque ont
déménagé rapidement après cette histoire
parce que elle n'arrivait plus à dormir
la nuit tellement ça l'a marqué alors
l'histoire pourrait s'arrêter là sauf
que m
elle a des souvenirs d'un truc qui s'est
passé ce jour là à l'époque dont elle
n'a jamais parlé liée à sa mère ni aux
policiers ni à nadia sa copine en fait à
l'époque ce jour là dans l'après midi
anne elle est partie de chez nadia pour
aller chez elle cherchait un cahier de
dessin qu'elle voulait montrer à nadia
elle arrive chez elle la porte était
verrouillée elle a déverrouillé
elle rentre et la mauvais feeling ya
aucun signe d'effraction aucun bruit
aucun objet qui n'est pas à sa place
habituelle mais elle a un mauvais finie
et elle a tellement un mauvais feeling
qu'elle va pas dans sa chambre elle
préfère faire demi tour et elle part de
chez elle directement
elle serait pas expliqué pourquoi elle a
fait ça ce jour là mais elle a vraiment
pris peur de fouet à tel point que en
arrivant chez nadia elle avait honte de
ce qu'elle venait de faire elle a quand
même 15 ans elle se dit mais
attends je viens vraiment d'avoir peur
parce que je suis seul chez moi mais
chacune
sauf que non son instinct avait
totalement raison et avait très
certainement ce mec qui était déjà dans
la maison et c'est ça qui fait que cette
histoire est la marque et c'est qu'elle
sait que ce jour là elle a failli être
traumatisé bien plus fort en tombant sur
un inconnu né à mener seule chez elle et
elle est persuadée d'avoir bel et bien
fermé la porte d'entrée à clé et donc
elle sait toujours pas comment ce mec a
pu rentrer chez elle voilà morale de
l'histoire
ne fermez pas votre porte ça ne sert à
rien les gens rentrent quand même
excusez moi je me suis accordé une pause
parce que l'autre là la deuxième
j'aime pas du tout c'est l'histoire de
lyonnais oui c'est un prénom coréen et
c'est normal ça se passe en corée à
cette époque youn et vit donc dans un
complexe d'appartements assez haut elle
est mère au foyer elle a une jeune fille
de 6 ans et son mari travaille toute la
journée ce jour-là elle revient des
courses qu'elle a fait avec sa fille
en arrivant dans son immeuble elle
appelle l'ascenseur et quand les portes
s'ouvrent elle tombe sur un mec qui
porte un imperméable jaune et une
casquette vraiment dressé vers le bain
et en plus de ça l'homme baisse lui même
la tête ce qui fait qu'elle ne peut
absolument pas voir son visage s'était
pas qu'une histoire de style
c'était vraiment une envie d'être
incognito elles rendent quand même dans
l'ascenseur mais elle a un instinct
maternel et elle pousse sa fille à
l'opposé de l'homme avec sa main elle
appuie alors sur le numéro 12
puisqu'elle habite au 12e étage et elle
se rend compte à ce moment là que aucun
autre numéro n'est allumé sauf que
l'inconnu avec elle dans l'ascenseur
n'est pas descendu au rez de chaussée
elle décide alors de jeter discrètement
des coups d'oeil à l'inconnu elle
remarque qui tient quelque chose dans sa
main enveloppé dans du papier journal
lyonnais comprend qu'elle est très
probablement dans une situation très
dangereuse et elle a un réflexe
incroyable
elle prend son portable et elle fait
semblant d'appeler son mari en faisant
croire qu'il est à la maison donc au 12e
étage dans l'appartement sauf qu'en
réalité il n'est pas du tout à
l'appartement son mari il est au travail
elle dit quand même à haute voix qu'elle
est dans l'ascenseur qu'elle va pas
tarder à arriver devant la porte
d'entrée et lui demande fectivement de
venir lui ouvrir la porte et de l'aider
à rentrer les courses dans l'appartement
elle fait semblant de raccrocher et
quelques secondes plus tard l'ascenseur
arrive enfin au 12e étage elle attrape
sa fille elle descend de l'ascenseur et
elle marche aussi vite qu'elles peuvent
vers la porte de son appartement
elle fait donc semblant d'attendre que
son mari lui ouvre la porte et du coin
de l'oeil
elle voit l'inconnu s'arrêter puis faire
demi-tour et retourner vers l'ascenseur
et elle commence à taper le code pour
ouvrir sa porte d'entrée problème quand
elle appuie sur le premier chiffre ça
fait un bruit et ce bruit l'inconnu
l'entente aussitôt il comprend que
personne n'est là pour venir ouvrir à
you n'est que depuis le début elle a
totalement feinte et la pseudo présence
de son mari dans l'appartement l'inconnu
se retourne et se met à courir vers
yonnais lyonnais d'appeler chiffres du
code à toute vitesse
la porte se déverrouille elle jette sa
fille à l'intérieur et elle claque la
porte derrière elle alors quel inconnu
est à seulement quelques centimètres de
la porte
l'inconnue n'a pas eu le temps de
glisser son pied ou son arme dans
l'ouverture de la porte pour l'empêcher
de se fermer immédiatement youn et
regarde à travers l'oeil de la porte et
elle voit l'homme s'éloigner et prendre
de nouveau la direction de l'ascenseur
le soir lyonnais explique évidemment ce
qui s'est passé à son mari et
heureusement elle ne croise pas de
nouveau cet homme au cas où john et ses
cinq mois plus tard qu'elle découvre ce
à quoi elle a échappé ce jour là grâce à
sa feinte légendaire du mari qui
soi-disant l'attendait dans son appart
elle passe devant un kiosque et la
couverture du journal attire tout de
suite son intention puisque c'est une
photo d'un homme qui a un k-way jaune et
cet homme il a exactement la même
carrure que l'homme à qui elle a échappé
ce jour là en rentrant chez elle et qui
vient d'être arrêté par la police pour
avoir tué plusieurs femmes
majoritairement des prostituées lyonnais
ce jour là elle a eu un sens de
l'observation de dengue et ça lui a
sauvé la vie tout simplement je serais
mort 300 fois à la place de lyonnais
pour la simple et bonne raison que
j'aurais été sur mon téléphone jours et
a capté à ce gala côté de moi et il
faudrait trucider
messieurs dames il est temps de passer à
la troisième et dernière histoire je
sais ça passe vite et vous êtes triste
mais y aura d'autres et doit vous en
faites pas d'ailleurs juin met à jour la
playlist raid horreur si vous êtes en
manque vous en avez forcément raté deux
ou trois aller piocher là dedans et
devrait avoir votre bonheur bref laissez
moi vous raconter l'histoire de max et
13 vaccins thèse ce sont deux filles qui
ont la vingtaine et qui ont soif de road
trip elles en font chaque année et cette
année là elles ont décidé de partir de
new york de zigzaguer à travers tous les
états unis est d'arriver six semaines
plus tard à los angeles
maïs et elles sont jeunes elles ont pas
trop de moyens et pour économiser une
tonne d'argent elles vont pas louer un
énorme camping car elles vont tout
simplement utiliser la berline de la
maman de tess berline qui est assez
grande et qu'elles vont aménagé pour
l'occasion pour que chacun ait sa petite
couche est cette année la mac ses thèses
elles ont dormi dans plein d'endroits
différents des parkings des camping
gratuit des aires de repos elle explique
que tout se passe est merveilleusement
bien elles se sont pas sentis une seule
seconde en danger jusqu'à la dernière
semaine de leur voyage en arizona
cette nuit là c'est une nuit qui était
pas très différente de toutes celles
qu'elles ont traversé jusqu'à présent la
particularité c'est que ce camping la la
ville la plus proche étaient assez loin
mais bon c'était le cas d'autres
campings auquel elle était déjà allé
donc ça les a pas plus fait flipper que
ça en arrivant sur les lieux elles sont
pas seuls il ya un camping-car qu'égarer
et plus loin il ya deux voitures
elle se gare à ses proches du camping
car et un homme en ouvre la porte des
jeux lui fait un signe de la main elle
est contente à l'idée de rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes
sauf que l'homme reste immobile et la
fixe elles comprennent tout de suite que
c'est peut-être quelqu'un qui veut de
l'intimité et qu'elles ont peut-être pas
été cool à ce gars est aussi proche du
camping car elle roule alors un peu plus
loin sur la route elle se gare sur un
terrain plat non loin des deux autres
voitures elles boivent quelques bières
elles prennent des photos elles vivent
leur meilleure vie deux meilleurs potes
et elle remarque au loin qu'un peu plus
bas dans le cette zone de camping et un
feu de camp à la recherche de nouvelles
rencontres
elle décide d'y aller autour du feu de
camp il ya deux hommes et c'est donc les
deux propriétaires des voitures garées
non loin de la voiture de thèse et max
les deux hommes ont l'air sympa ils sont
eux aussi en train de discuter du coup
max et s assoit et commence à discuter
avec au fil de la discussion mac ses
thèses comprennent que l'un des deux est
plutôt gêné et celui qui est gêné et qui
est d'ailleurs un peu plus vieux que
l'autre a l'air aussi d'avoir pris de la
drogue mais la balle a pour autant
dangereux au contraire il a l'air trés
inoffensif et perchée dans ce monde du
coup elles vont essentiellement discuté
avec le deuxième homme et ce deuxième
homme apparemment c'est un ancien garde
forestier il est décontracté chill beau
mood et pendant plusieurs heures ils
vont chacun échanger au sujet de leur
voyage leur femme
de leur vision de la vie etc et puis cet
homme commença à parler de l'ours
ouais il leur dit que quelques heures
plus tôt il a aperçu un ours au loin qui
faisait des tours autour de la zone de
camping et en vrai c'est un truc plutôt
fréquents parce qu'ils savent qu'il ya
de la nourriture et donc des fois ils
viennent de gratter de la bouffe
m'acceptait zèle bad un peu parce que
souvent la nuit elle se lève pour aller
aux toilettes et donc elles ont tout
sauf envie de se faire agresser par un
ours en pleine nuit et d'un ton très
sérieux il leur explique que si elles
sortent de leur voiture au beau milieu
de la nuit c'est pas que d'amour dont il
devrait s'inquiéter
ah bon elles sont pas très sereine elle
regarde le deuxième homme heureusement
il est toujours en plein trip est
parfaitement inoffensif
et puis l'heure un garde forestier se
lève et va vers la glacière pour se
prendre une nouvelle bière à ce stade on
est dans la forêt il fait nuit noire et
donc tout ce qui n'est pas très proche
du feu de camps et plongé dans
l'obscurité et n'est pas visible et
c'est le cas de la glacière max et s
regarde quand même en direction de vers
là où il est parti et après plusieurs
secondes de noir elle voit un point
rouge apparaître le ranger est dans
l'obscurité
à quelques mètres d'elle et il vient
apparemment de prendre une photo d'elle
elle reste bouche bée parce que
généralement avant de prendre des gens
en photo tu leur demandes
et puis vient se rasseoir avec elle près
du feu comme si s'était rien passé
max et thèses immédiatement ne sont pas
du tout rassuré elle se lève elle
explique aux deux hommes qu'il est tard
et qu'elles doivent y aller le vieil
homme toujours dans son trip leur
souhaite bonne nuit l'ancien rangers lui
les regardent avec un sourire aux lèvres
et leur dit de faire attention parce que
là-bas dans les bois il y a plus que des
ours
immédiatement elle se demande pourquoi
il les a prises en photo surtout sans
dire un mot sont demandés sans rien
c'est super bizarre et max se souvient
qu'elle a vu un documentaire sur les
tueurs en série et que certains d'entre
eux parfois avertissent leurs victimes
malgré l'obscurité elle retrouve la
voiture elle rentre à l'intérieur max
démarre alors la voiture et allume les
phares pour la direction du chemin de
terre qu'elles ont emprunté pour arriver
au camping et en regardant dans son
rétroviseur
elle voit le ranger de bush sur le
chemin de terre marchant vers elle en
souriant avant de le voir disparaître
dans l'obscurité
à cause d'eux
à distance cette nuit là ils ont roulé
une heure et demie de plus que prévu
avant de trouver un endroit où se garer
dormir dans la voiture et surtout elles
ont fait la première et dernière
rencontre vraiment badens de leur
périple avec ce fameux ancien manager
qui apparemment ne voulait pas que du
bien et surtout ce qui est bizarre c'est
que avant ce switch elles ont parlé avec
lui pendant deux trois heures et le mec
était cool bon délire sympa c'était
chouette quoi elles ont réalisé d'un
coup qu'elle n'était pas du tout en
sécurité alors qu'elles ont été très
sereine pendant deux heures avant ce à
quoi bref c'est la fin de ce serait
d'horreur j'espère qu'il vous a plu
j'espère que ces trois histoires vous
ont plu et je suis un peu deg parce que
j'adorerais un jour faire un road trip
mais vraiment j'adore mais j'ai
tellement peur mec de ce truc de
mauvaises rencontres c'est terrible ça
je redoute et je suis tellement naïfs
les gens naïfs que moi on se ferait
déglingué on verrait rien venir moi le
mec en k-way jaune là dans l'ascenseur
je leur ai proposé de l'aide
bref a très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo dans un prochain sera d'horreur on
essaie d'en faire un tous les mois je
vous le rappelle courage à ceux qui
partent en retraite commun c'est ciao
[Musique]